Wow
I can't believe that you got Darren
Rhodes for the show
yes he's hard to get he's very hard to
get that guy well you know why why
because of his razzmatazz yeah he goes
for full razzmatazz where you don't hear
enough anymore not enough how are you
you look good thank you
I didn't mean it that way actually
working razzmatazz into the answer and
now you'll get it in later on in the
interview it'll show up somewhere now
yes like if you can come up with it
you've got this everyone's talking about
this friends finale is gonna be one of
those huge television events that that
everybody sort of everyone gathers
around the TV and watches this
it must have been emotional cuz it's
already been shot is that true yeah just
to about two weeks ago you shot it
wasn't it was it an incredibly intense
evening I was really in it was strange
for me I mean I'm I I'm not really one
of the group I just kind of came on I
feel a little bit like a d-h you know
and they've been together for 10 years
but it was pretty emotional
certainly for them was I was honored to
be in it but there were there's a lot a
lot of crying and like when the final
taping was done and yeah and I just even
during the during the the read-through
or during the taping and III I felt as
if I absolutely I shouldn't be there I
felt was advised was like watching
somebody bathe that just wasn't right
but then I would I would kind of
overcompensate and go up to them like
there was Marta Kauffman and Jennifer
Aniston and Marta Kauffman the creator
of the show generally holding on to each
other having this really amazing moment
and I would go over and go what a ride
[Laughter]
[Applause]
you're a bad guy tell me you only did
that once I hope well I I did it a few
times
oh that's and then I think they actually
kind of got a little no I did it I think
I did did Jeff Zucker no VC and he's not
serious I think yeah I think he was just
like oh yeah it has been
yeah that's that should be your
catchphrase you should just walk around
the candy time you see anybody like what
razzmatazz do this show you could do
wait a minute you just yeah yeah you
can't just say razzmatazz it's got to
make sense really work in that situation
you really get was amazing I you know I
I actually just got they sent me a tape
sometimes you have to like actors will
have to approve a clip or a photo or
something alike Necedah go they're going
to use and I actually brought a clip
from the final epilim the final episode
they're not supposed to I mean that
that's on total lockdown no one's
supposed to see that right I know but no
one told me that I'd have to sign
anything and uh actors always saying to
you like when you know I brought a clip
and that's not true we don't really have
clips and bring them along but but this
time I did I brought it to you this is a
clip of the final episodes and I thought
maybe you could show it well I'm just
gonna show it that's why not but we
might get in some trouble here but it
long as it doesn't care as long as it
doesn't give anything away and a lot of
interest let's show this clip from the
final episode of France
[Music]
[Applause]
but I didn't see that coming I have to
say I know doesn't see it going that way
it's a lot of surprises in the last
episode wow it was pretty emotional I
mean as you could see Matthew Perry was
in a wheelchair you know he's great you
know they're all friends in real life
they are yeah now I know that you
pitched you went to the network and you
you pitched because we talked about this
last time a spinoff from friends that
would star you oh yeah I mean they
didn't go for it because no one it tell
them the idea gangs it's such a good
idea I thought I'd just be about me call
friend show everyone thought you know in
the beginning just in a fountain by
myself then in the old umbrella yeah and
you sold that idea they didn't go for it
I don't know I mentioned to him and they
said they didn't say anything actually
and I maybe you can't just mention it to
him you got to really pitch it to him
with a lot of energy you got to get the
pitch a little razzmatazz
I'm thinking say it again
present tax all right now listen whoops
what's it does somebody else have to
come anyone tuned it tunes in just now
they'll be confused
I need that later on to know who you are
there we go now I'm losing my mind
I totally am sitting in you know I'm
sitting in water right now I hope so why
don't we just hear this back and pull
this back here and then shove this over
there we go
[Applause]
Paul this razzmatazz yeah there's little
razzmatazz I there what host does that
rearranges the furniture for the guests
nobody see my heart attack all right
Montel but beyond my only one Montel
alright we had more to talk about but we
wasted time with your babbling I always
trying to conduct a serious interview
and you ruin it see Phoebe and Mike's
wedding next Thursday night at 8:00 on
nbc15 to that Paul rod always great
[Applause]
[Music]